[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur tennis
welt mit
ja wir zwei stehen heute gemeinsam in
der küche weil wir vor kurzem gemeinsam
im synchronstudio standen ihr duft
nämlich unsere stimmen den beiden
charakteren im neuen film boss baby
schluss mit kindergarten ein und zwar
spreche ich die rolle carroll und du
sprecht keine frauen und texter ist
meine tochter jan bosse wie teil 1 war
ich schon ganz kurz mitarbeiter hatte
ich die rolle der flugbegleiterin zwei
drei sätze und dieses mal haben sie uns
angefragt ob wir nicht mit samira
zusammen und es kann zu machen wollen
und ich kann dazu sagen es war sehr
aufregend für uns und vor allem war es
ja auch für dich sehr aufregend denn wir
waren da dort und ich habe sie mir nicht
verraten dass sie tatsächlich auch
genommen wurde und das ist wirklich
klappt und wollte eigentlich
überraschend mit dem trailer der dann
geschnitten wurde auch den hat sie dann
schon auf youtube entdeckt jamal die
überraschung weg gelegt sondern bis man
so aufgeregt hergekommen läuft mache ich
auch meine stimme gehört auf youtube
jetzt erzähl mal wie war es für dich so
dass synchronsprechen
es war toll
es war auch etwas anstrengend kann man
sagen
was daran warum springt also ich mein
halt das genauso perfekt wie sehr die
originalstimme ihr müsst euch vorstellen
wir durften uns morgens zusammen den
film auf englisch anschauen also das
original und weil es auch schwierig
natürlich für dich alles zu verstehen
aus dem contact hat es gut verstanden
ich habe es dann immer wird er übersetzt
und dann standen wir im synchronstudio
und dann hört man zuerst die
originalstimme die englische stimme hat
den text vor sich und dann treffen sich
da so zwei balken und genau dann darf
man anfangen zu sprechen muss mit der
gleichen strecke geschwindigkeit und
natürlich auch mit den gleichen
emotionen sprechen und es schon
schwierig es auf anhieb zu lachen zu
weinen oder wütend oder traurig zu sein
das war glaube ich so das anstrengendste
oder der arbeit muss sagen mir hat das
richtig gut gemacht dass sogar sagen
besser als ich teilweise weil du einfach
so kinder sind da einfach so ein
bisschen emotionaler und denen es ist
vollkommen egal wie man dabei aussieht
und ob man sich zum affen macht oder
nicht geld aber uns wurde auch recht
einfach gemacht werden nämlich echt ein
tolles synchronstudio der marius der
synchron regisseur dort da ist echt
super der spricht auch selber ganz viele
stimmen die kennt ihr auch und er hat
auch hier im film die stimme gesprochen
aber jetzt gucken uns erst mal ein
bisschen backstage an und damit den
trailer kennenlernen
tina
was machst du denn da ich musste jetzt
mal zeigen wir das richtig
ich bin gespannt ich habe angst
was machst du denn da
könntest du grad an den tag nach
weihnachten das ist
ja
was machst du denn da
er fiel ins wasser von meiner seite aus
witten muss
ja ein format das ganze für uns wir
waren insgesamt glaube ich eine woche in
berlin
und falls er jetzt lust auf den film
bekommen hat sind noch den trailer
zusammen an
es ist einsam an der spitze
es ist meine kleine mein kleiner bruder
ted er interessiert sich bloß für seine
arbeit aber er vergisst nie zu
besonderen anlässen unangemessen
großzügige geschenke zu schicken
gute nacht
bist du nicht ich bin langsam bis ins
alter führen okay ich habe angst dass
twitter und ich uns auseinander leben so
wie mein bruder und ich aber die zeit
lässt sich eben nicht zurückdrehen
ohne ende diese magische schafft
die kindheit bleibt dann nicht für immer
aber die verlosung endlich mal loslegen
ich vermisse meine zeit stress dich so
wahnsinnig er ist die peinlich oder
ich will einfach nur dass er stolz auf
mich ist
alles was gemacht hat wollte die auch
tun
jeden morgen wenn du aufwachst bin ich
da und du und ich wir werden brüder
seien für immer da will ich direkt ein
trauriges gesicht aufsetzen
immer zusammen
was machen familien so
der gefängnisausbruch auf mein team nach
dir die hölle los
erfolg und misserfolg
ich gebe mich wie ich muss darauf
das geschäftsjahr haben wir mit wir
meine ich mich und das pony
[Musik]
ich freue mich jetzt auch schon richtig
auf den film ab dem 14 oktober läuft
baby schluss mit kindergarten in allen
deutschen kinos und wir haben ihnen auch
noch nicht gesehen also mit unseren
originalstimmen grünen und sanierer
durfte sogar singen
das mache ich die schwer aber das ist
richtig richtig gut gemacht ich werde
jetzt schon mal wenigstens im kino
sitzen es tut mir leid ich habe
versprochen nicht zu weinen es tue ich
weiß ich finde richtig spießig
langweilig weil ich mama ich weise aber
mach ich bin also
hab ich okay okay ich hatte nicht zurück
ja absolut ich gesagt ab dem 14 10 in
allen deutschen kinos ja jeden fall
haben wir uns gedacht ist zum anlass
dieses films müssen wir natürlich
natürlich eine torte backen die tore
steht auch schon die ganze zeit im bild
das ist nämlich diese hier im film geht
es nämlich darum dass eine magische
milch getrunken wird und mit dieser
magischen baby milch wird man von einem
erwachsenen wieder zurückverwandelt zu
einem baby und deswegen machen wir jetzt
zusammen dieser babyflaschen und zwar
ist es eine schokoladen flasche eine
schokoladen hülle wie beim einer coca
cola torte und im inneren versteckt sich
ein kuchen und das besondere daran ist
falls ihr jetzt an dieser flasche auch
mal machen wollt für eine baby gender
partie für eine baby shower party oder
was auch immer dann könnt ihr hier die
farben einfach nur abwandeln das innere
befüllen wie ihr möchtet und daneben die
torte so gestalten wie es eben zu eurem
anlass am besten passt und wir machen es
jetzt so ich mache jetzt meine eigene
flasche und du darfst deine eigene
flasche machen okay wir machen so eine
art metal und die zuschauer dürfen dann
drunter schreiben welche flasche die
coolere ist dürfte aber auch schreiben
dass beide flaschengrößen also auf los
geht's los
jetzt können wir nicht zuerst um die
flasche die babyflasche und dafür nehmt
ihr euch am besten wpt flasche die
einfach eine schöne größe hat hier war
jetzt ein saft drin ich habe es ja schon
ausgewaschen und trocknen lassen am
entweder nimmt in der flasche komplett
oder rillen ist natürlich eigentlich
besser zum später raus nehmen die hat
jetzt das ist jetzt auch gar nicht
schlimm ich hatte ja auch mal eine cola
flaschen torte gemacht und da habe ich
dann so gemacht da sich die flasche erst
mal auseinander geschnitten habe habe
sie dann mit esel wieder zugeklebt und
sie dann befüllt dann kann man nämlich
später das ganze einfach entfernen und
auseinanderziehen das wird jetzt hier
sowieso nicht funktioniert wegen den
rillen deswegen werde ich die später
einfach zerschneiden wenn die schokolade
fest ist von daher passt das ganz gut
aber wie gesagt trocken muss sie sein
und jetzt nehme ich hier weiße
schokolade weil es eben auch aussieht
wie milch passt perfekt dann nehmt ihr
am besten eine wirklich hochwertige
schokolade ich habe immer die von
callebaut und habe jetzt hier eine
methode für euch wie ihr die schokolade
temperieren könnt und das ist auch
wichtig damit später diese schokoladen
hülle dieser hohlkörper eben auch
standfest bleibt auch wenn dann was drin
ist und wenn die befüllt ist und
deswegen macht ihr sitzt so falls ihr
kein thermometer zur hand habt nehmt ihr
einfach zwei drittel der schokolade die
wir jetzt direkt geschmolzen ich habe
hier auch schon wasser aufkochen lassen
und vom heruntergenommen das machte
jetzt hier schön in einem wasserbad
zwei drittel hier rein das heißt bei mir
einfach 300 gramm und die lasse ich
jetzt hier schmelzen nimmst dann vom
wasserbad runter und frühere dann das
restliche drittel ein so bekommt die
kuvertüre einfach die perfekte weiter
verarbeitungs temperatur und man sieht
auch die auf der verpackung immer ganz
gut die temperatur prof die man machen
muss damit die schokolade eben perfekt
kristallin wird und eben auch perfekt
aushärtet und hier erhitzt man die eben
zuerst auf etwa 45 grad das ist eben
dieses wasserbad einmal kochen lassen
vom herd runtergenommen dann ist es auch
nicht mehr zu heiß und mit der chor türe
mit der festen wird sie später einfach
herunter gekühlt falls ihr kenwood habt
dann könnt ihr hier auch ganz einfach 45
grad eingeben und wirklich erstmal die
zwei drittel schmelzen dann die
temperatur unternehmen und daneben das
restliche drittel
so können das auch machen und am ende
sollte die kuvertüre einfach etwa 29
grad haben dann ist perfekt
jetzt einfach schön ohne hitze weiter
rühren bis alles geschmolzen ist und
dann soll dass sie die perfekte
temperatur haben und ihr seht ob mit
oder ohne maschine es klappt einfach
wunderbar
so seht ihr jetzt die perfekt
geschmolzene schokolade aus
die wird jetzt hier eingefüllt und
achtet bei der flasche wirklich drauf
das ist eine schöne form ist nicht zu
schmal nicht so hoch ich glaube das ist
eine schöne babyflasche ich meine es ist
schon ein bisschen xxl rabatte stars der
tatorte jetzt hier einfüllen
das war einfach eine mit einem liter
inhalt jetzt den deckel verschließen und
langsam die flasche drehen
damit sich die kuvertüre überall
verteilen kann
und dann stelle ich es jetzt gleich oder
legt sie gleich ins gefrierfach und zwar
so rein und dre sie dann immer mal so
die ersten paar minuten bis die
schokolade fest wird damit die sich
wirklich schön verteilen kann wenn es
draußen schon kalt ist dann könnt ihr
jetzt machen wie damals beim einer
colaflasche da geht ja einfach raus im
garten auf die terrasse oder auf dem
balkon und könnte wirklich auf einem
kalten stein hin und her rollen oder
hier so akku kühlpads hinlegen und das
dann eben so machen was ich hier wichtig
finde dass er sie auch mal hin stellt
damit ein bisschen schokolade auch am
boden steht damit sie später wenn sie
gefüllt ist nicht umkippt sodass
wirkliches gewicht so ein bisschen auch
am boden ist aber ansonsten hatte
sitzungen ich muss jetzt nur gucken dass
die sich gleichmäßig verteilt und ich
mache jetzt gleich noch eine zweite für
die familie
[Musik]
während die flasche festwirt kümmere ich
mich jetzt schon mal um den inhalt ihr
könnt die flasche später entweder mit
löffelbiskuits füllen und sozusagen noch
belasten also ganz ohne doppel backofen
mit kühlschrank natürlich aber ohne
backofen oder ihr könnt sagen ich war
kidman twist wird wenn ihr jetzt eine
gender revealed orte machen wollt und
verkünden volt mädchen oder junge und
eine bestimmte farbe rosa blau lila bund
regenbogenfarben was auch immer dann
könnt ihr auch den biskuit zum beispiel
ein bisschen einfärben das auch ganz
hübsch finde ich magazinen bist wird für
den bug rahmen aber nur ein halbes blech
deswegen auch nur 250 gramm zucker etwas
salz und vanille extrakt und 50 gramm
mehl ihr könnt ja das backen verwenden
oder ganz normales weizenmehl ihr könnt
backpulver dazu geben etwa einen halben
oder viertel teelöffel ihr müsst aber
nicht also hier könnte jetzt sagen okay
ich mache schnellen bist wird schneller
bis mit bedeutet ich nehm back mail oder
eben backpulver dazu und verrührt die
eier jetzt nicht extrem lange wenn ihr
die eier mit dem zucker aber lange
verrührt dann könnt ihr auch ganz ohne
backpulver arbeiten das war der
unterschied ich gebe es hier also die
eier in die rührschüssel
dann den zucker dazu
salz und vanille extrakt und
kurz rühren
[Musik]
so weiß cremig reicht es jetzt auch
schon und brauche ich kein handrührgerät
mehr
neben das mehl und das sieht dir jetzt
dazu oder wenn es das back mir das muss
man es nicht 7 und das könnte jetzt ganz
kurz unterheben
[Musik]
und das war es schon jetzt habe ich ja
wirklich nur eine ganz kleine portion
und backt deswegen im halben blech und
wenn ihr hier den bug rahmen nimmt und
den einfach zusammen schiebt dann ist es
schon das halbe blech also fast perfekt
ihr könnt aber und der springform nehmen
und den kuchen darin backen jetzt schön
einfüllen der ofen ist auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 210 grad
einfach kurz verteilen und sofort backen
die flasche ist jetzt fest man sieht es
auch von außen weil sich die schokolade
von der flasche so ein bisschen ab löst
also die ist nicht mehr so press dran
das heißt sie ist jetzt gut fest
geworden jetzt kann ich die flasche
drumrum wegschneiden
ich habe da übrigens hinten sonne magnet
dran und damit kann man wirklich diese
einzelnen messer schön raus nehmen ohne
sich zu verletzen
dann oben rein drin und fixieren fertig
jetzt
fange ich hier einfach vorsichtig mit
ich an
jetzt einfach schön geduldig arbeiten
und die flasche abziehen
[Musik]
man muss er hier wirklich nur an diesen
rillen vorbeikommt der rest löst sich
echt ganz gut
jetzt muss ich natürlich noch eine
öffnung einschneiden ihr könnt entweder
jetzt seitlich eine öffnung ein
schneiden oder hier zum beispiel an
seinem ring einfach runter schneiden
später wieder zusammenkleben ich werde
es allerdings so machen ich mache jetzt
hier oben einfach den deckel weg weil
später sowieso diese flasche drauf kommt
also von der baby milchflasche jetzt
nehmt ihr euch ein scharfes messer
erhitzt es vorher gut entweder mit einem
bunsenbrenner heißes wasser in bis
laufen heiße pfanne legen mit heißluft
füllen geht auch gut
und dann vorsichtig wegschneiden
[Musik]
das hat jetzt wunderbar funktioniert die
flasche stelle ich jetzt noch mal kurz
in den kühlschrank der biscuit ist
fertig und auch mittlerweile abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich noch eine schöne
creme machen wer hitler süßigkeiten
zusammensuchen und dann wird die torte
gefüllt ich werde jetzt auch gleich so
machen dass ich wahrscheinlich einfach
kunterbunte süßigkeiten mit drei mache
falls in der baby schänder torte machen
wollt könnt ihr dann eben entscheiden
welche farbe ihre süßigkeiten haben
sollen und was eben aus dem innern
später heraus fallen soll
dafür nehme ich 200 gramm frischkäse 40
gramm puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt
seiner fahrt zum steif schlagen und 200
gramm sahne es geht jetzt auch ganz
einfach ihr verrückt einfach alle
zutaten miteinander und schlag zwischen
steif pro 100 gramm masse also einen
teelöffel sommerbad das heißt bei 200 km
frischkäse und 200 gramm sahne einfach
insgesamt vier teelöffel
sind dann noch puderzucker und mannil
extrakt und schön steif schlagen
so sieht die creme jetzt aus
dann habe ich jetzt hier den biscuit und
den könnte jetzt mit gläsern oder mit
ausstellern einfach nur rund ausstechen
[Musik]
zum film nehme ich jetzt noch hippies
das müsst ihr nicht machen aber ich
finde in so ner in so einer babyflasche
darf das schon mal drin sein ist eine
schöne kleines baby zu pflegen so ein
paar bunte süßigkeiten jetzt habe ich
hier die biskuits meine creme habe ich
auch schon in einen spritzbeutel trifft
mit einer lok hülle weil das befüllen
eben einfacher ist und ich mache jetzt
so und da gebe ich jetzt direkt auf den
flaschenboden
dann kommt immer einfach so ein bisschen
drauf die creme drauf und so schicht ich
jetzt die komplette flasche
da könnt ihr jetzt wirklich drin stecken
was ihr wollt
[Musik]
es hat sich jetzt mal kurz darauf kann
die torte jetzt gefüllt in den
kühlschrank stellen und welche um die
deko kümmern nämlich die den
babyflaschen auf sagt ich bin so ein
bisschen aus der babysprache hausnummer
aufsatz
babyfläschchen verschluss
das weiche da oben
[Gelächter]
ja
meine kinder sind schon groß
hack slay
geständnisse aus der kindheit was habt
ihr sind angestellt von dem eure eltern
bis heute nichts wissen also ich kann
jetzt nicht alles verraten dass er
geheim aber mama papa ich war nicht
immer mit leder mathe lernen vielleicht
waren wir auch aber zu feiern
zum modellieren nehme ich jetzt hier den
kormoran ist lässt sich nämlich super
einfach verarbeiten ihr könnt aber auch
von dort nehmen und das ganze mit blüten
passte mission damit davon dann eben
schön modelliert fähig wird und auch
festwirt bei marzipan kann ich einfach
dekor marzipan benutzen und weiß er
jetzt wirklich eine post babyflasche
wird werde ich jetzt hier einmal schwarz
verwenden weiß brauche ich ein bisschen
und hier habe ich noch so einen helleren
ton gemischt den es eben ganz oft an
diesem nuckelflaschen gibt und daraus
vor mich jetzt erstmal den sauger
da habe ich einfach irgendwas und
bisschen rot und gelb gemischt an
lebensmittelfarben
und jetzt kommt ihr hier oben die
spitze
und dann könnt ihr hier mit einem
ausstecher das ganze einmal wirklich
schön rund machen das war's schon
das so einzel betrachtet nämlich
bisschen weiß
form einem eine schöne rolle für den
rand
einfach schön gleichmäßig und die
commerzbank ist perfekt war uns wirklich
nicht lange kneten muss es ist einfach
immer schön weich
und ist einfach so lang dass es einmal
hier drumherum passt anpassen kann ich
es gleich noch
und das schwarze hier wird jetzt der st
verschluss also der drehverschluss und
falls ihr jetzt ohne baby schänder torte
oder einfach eine baby torte machen
wollt könnt ihr hier jetzt eine schöne
farbe verwenden irgendwas passt einiges
zum beispiel aber zum boss weniger hat
natürlich die schwarze agenten flasche
das erst mal eine kugel formen und immer
wenn es so anfängt ein bisschen zu
kleben könnt ihr bäcker stärke verwenden
dann wird schön geschmeidig
und die kugel bislang flach drücken
und damit zentrum roms schöne struktur
bekommt könnt ihr ein modell ihr
werkzeug nehmen oder die rückseite eines
messers da könnt ihr wirklich auch ganz
normales haushaltsmesser benutzen und
hier die rückseite nehmen und das ganze
hier so ein bisschen einprägen
und dann immer mal rund formen und noch
mal flach drücken
ist der kreis ein bisschen größer als
die flasche ist
jetzt werde ich hier oben das ganze noch
mal ein bisschen flach machen am besten
mit einer warmen pfanne oder waren
teekanne so könnt ihr nämlich den oberen
teilen der schokolade einfach schmelzen
und der schöne nebeneffekt ist dass die
weiche schokolade jetzt das ganze klebt
am drücker
das sah sich kurz hier stehen
einfach mit so ein bisschen gewicht
damit schön ankleben kann
und dann habe ich hier schon mal aus
fondant und belaste das habe ich gemacht
und ausgerollt das wird jetzt ein
etikett ihr könnt jetzt theoretisch die
flasche so lassen und hier mit
lebensmittel stiften ich habe hier diese
filzstifte sind aber lebensmittel
stifter könnte die beschriftung drauf
machen wenn ihr wollt oder ihr könnt
sagen okay ich bastele jetzt noch ein
schönes etikett so hab ich das jetzt
nämlich und kann da nämlich hier darauf
malen und es später dann einmal
drumherum kleben und so finde ich es
eigentlich ganz hübsch und werde jetzt
hier also wenn es jetzt eine baby jet
otto würde ich jetzt schreiben ist
burger und so kann man so kann ich jetzt
hier das baby draufschreiben
aber achtet darauf das motiv eher so ein
bisschen mittig zu lassen weil ganz dumm
kann man gar nicht schauen deswegen hat
man so einen bereich wie hier und da
kann man jetzt alles schön drauf
schreiben ganz dicht dran an ich hab dir
gedacht dass ich eine bunte flasche mag
also eher gesagt mit metallic farben
blau und
die wittern so aus
dann kommt darauf oben ein gelber
schnulli
und dann mache ich noch ein etikett auf
jetzt motiviere ich das etikett
ausbildner und von hand
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich den umgang der flasche
aus und das mache ich mit einer schmoren
ich hab jetzt von 20 zentimeter
das sind 12 10
ich habe mir das jetzt ausgeschnitten
das etikett und ich benutze das babykorb
logo drauf
hat es jetzt so etwas ausgeschnitten im
schnitt das gleich noch mal schön und
fein aus und dann lege ich mir das so
hin und geht einfach die linie nach und
da habe ich schon eine kleine skizze
[Musik]
ich habe hier diesem kreis heraus
geschnitten mit dem babykorb logo und
das hab ich mir zu finden in dem ich
mich hier einfach und steche
drückt es leicht an damit zu einem kreis
entsteht das ungefähre größe von dem
bild und gibt es nämlich hier einfach so
ein
kleines werkzeug das geht auch mit denen
ich glaube ich mache es mit dem und dann
gehe ich die schrift nach
ok ja es ist klar so
ok ich brauch jetzt
die stiftung
zeigt zuerst die schrift machen
du weißt ja du guckst du film ist ja das
war einmal
aber ich dachte jedoch jetzt mithelfen
okay ganz mit dem stifter angefangen
[Musik]
ok jetzt muss ich hier erst mal
aufräumen
und weil es eine babyflasche ist also
eine milchflasche kommen die csk dahin
auch einfach mit den lebensmittel
stiften und auch relativ weit vorne ich
weiß das sieht jetzt gequetscht aus aber
später kommt es echt ganz gut wenn das
hier ist
habe ich das etikett fertigt drehst
einmal um da kommt jetzt essbarer kleber
drauf auf die rückseite dorthin so gar
nicht sauber war farbe
und dann ankleben
wow jetzt richtig gemessen
und dann kommt der sauger hier auch um
drauf
[Musik]
und der ring drumrum
so ich möchte jetzt diese metallic
farben in diesem gefäß mit dem gitter
pulver zusammen und das kommt dann an
die äußere seite von der flasche
[Musik]
so jetzt mache ich den schnuller hat für
die flasche obendrauf und dafür brauche
ich jetzt weißen fondant und gelten vom
land ich mache jetzt erstmal
das weiß er das gelbe teil
oben drüber
und dafür knete ich jetzt so ein
länglicher form
und jetzt mache ich einen kreis
er gesagt eine kugel
und dann drücke ich das ein bisschen
platt
und jetzt tue ich auch schon die
rillenreifen würde ich sagen
hier drückt es nur so ein bisschen rein
passt es um ich denke
jetzt lebe ich das hier noch mit dem
essbaren kleber an
so
unterstreiche ich das noch etwas
[Musik]
so ich habe hier schon eine schnur
vorbereitet die dann tun kommt
ich hab hier wieder mein thema pinsel
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch mal den essbaren
kleber und das habe ich jetzt auf mein
etikett drauf gegeben
ich verstreiche hier gerade noch den
rest kleber für meine etikett zu gucken
dass ich es richtig drauf gebe
nein
es ist zu kurz drees kurzem ist
in ordnung
jetzt habe ich ja noch metallic farben
blau mal den ring an denn im film ist
die babyflasche hat auch oben zum
magischen ring zum blauen ring denn dass
er die magische mehr strecken
[Musik]
ich habe mich hier jetzt das ultimative
schwarzpulver
okay die stunde der wahrheit
das ist jetzt meine fertige boss baby
zauberte
[Musik]
also dass hier sind meine torte
ich finde deine tochter sieht schon
ziemlich cool aus
auch in china sind sehr gut okay ich bin
gespannt wie schmecken tun sehr gleich
und ihr dürft gerne mal schreiben was
ihr von unseren torten haltet dann würde
ich jetzt sagen holen wir sarah und
sarah darf auch mal probieren okay
die sieht richtig cool aus da war eine
richtige boss baby erwarte mega okay
dann schön aus wie schnell man die an
das machen wir jetzt als ich würde sagen
wenn ihr baby denn die torte macht haut
einfach drauf also ist auch nötig zum
flaggschiff logisch dann würde ich sagen
ich legte hin immer so schade um so eine
torte ging irgendwie schon aber
andererseits wären christoph becker
also und so hat man einfach
so wenn man kunst macht und die nicht
auf erst in form von bildern
kunstwerk
von der axt
bei uns ist kein geschlecht weil sie
haben eine woche besondere stimmt
da fühlt man das gabelt meine songs
man kriegt dann was von der weiße
schokolade am ende
ja
auch mit den weichen
[Musik]
wollte er mir auf dauer anschneiden
zu mir das spiel
jetzt möchte ich deine probieren die ist
ja cool
zwischen kleines talent richtig schön
geworden richtig gut baby
korkmaz ist es
ist dies käme penis erstellt man who
sieht echt cool aus sehr sehr gut
gemacht jetzt kann ich mich nicht
entscheiden welche besser aussieht
berger sieht ja auch richtig cool aus
innen drin
[Gelächter]
sehr lecker bunten farben
richtig cool
im durchmesser
ich nehme den guten
also optisch sind wir beide sehr
unterschiedlich geschmacklich beide
gleich und ihr könnt die ja auch
geschmacklich gestalten wie ihr möchtet
jedenfalls hat uns zu bereiten richtig
viel spaß gemacht und falls ihr die
torte nach macht dann macht gerne ein
foto la de des hoch und markiert mich
drauf und vor allem verpasst in förmlich
im kino wie gesagt ab dem 14 oktober
läuft boss baby schluss mit kindergarten
in allen deutschen kinos zu mir und ich
wir durften unsere stimmen den
charakteren carroll und tempel verleihen
und der film ist richtig richtig schön
als ich habe ihn ja wie gesagt schon auf
englisch anschauen dürfen und eine ganz
ganz tolle messe das wirklich im film
für die komplette familie aber auch für
alle die keine kinder haben deswegen
schau die nicht gerne an und falls ihr
im kino seit dann macht doch auch gerne
vor den filmplakaten ein foto und postet
ist und markiert und dann können wir es
wie posten und schreibt mir auch ganz
gerne wie ihr den film findet für mich
war es jedenfalls und auch für samira
eine richtig richtig schöne erfahrung
und
ja ich freue mich jetzt einfach auf den
deutschen film und auf den kinostart und
freue mich aufs nächste mal
[Musik]